ma motivation personnelle à l'origine
c'est que quand j'étais mère j'ai
malheureusement dû annoncer à une
famille que leur fils de 27 ans avait
été assassiné au Bataclan et donc je
regarde comme rapporteur des lois sur la
sécurité si tous les outils existent ou
pas dans notre dans notre arsenal pour
résister aux attentats terroristes
une première partie qui dit tout ce
qu'on ne peut pas faire qui est 90% des
cas et puis il y a sur quelques cas
d'usage qui concernent les services de
renseignement qui concernent le
terrorisme mais aussi des motifs quand
il y a magistrat donc c'est sous
l'autorité dans ce cas là magistrat
indépendant qui instruit une affaire
criminelle ou qui juge d'une affaire
criminelle pour les besoins de son
enquête donc on est vraiment dans le cas
de la séparation des pouvoirs et tout ça
sous contrôle renforcé du Parlement et
d'un comité indépendant d'éthique et de
scientifiques franchement on a rarement
fait une loi aussi protectrice des
libertés dans l'arsenal juridique
français
je réponds à tous ceux qui disent oh là
là on met le doigt dans un engrenage pas
du tout que justement on a mis toute une
série dans les premiers articles de
ligne rouge que le rapporteur Philippe
Bas est allé même plus loin que nous
qu'il a pour ce qu'il s'agit de la
reconnaissance faciale en temps réel
c'est à dire quand on authentifie un ou
deux présumés terroristes dans une foule
de 50 000 personnes qu'il a il faut une
autorisation préalable du Premier
ministre et de la Commission nationale
du renseignement et un avis du Conseil
d'État c'est à dire qu'on a mis toutes
les garanties juridiques pour éviter un
risque de dérapage qui pourrait se
produire ultérieurement avec un régime
dictatorial par hypothèse non justement
le Conseil constitutionnel il est là
pour garantir tout ça et on a mis toutes
les garanties qui existent dans notre
arsenal pour qu'on ait le maximum de
liberté et en même temps qu'on est une
sécurité renforcée parce que le
terrorisme ce n'est pas fini et les
risques qu'on le voit bien dans ce monde
très violent et de plus en plus violent
ne sont pas terminés et nous avons
trouvé je pense cet équilibre dans notre
proposition de Loire notre belle et
moi-même